[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with a kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining your suicide squad
we'll see my court date is coming up
and miss waller said maybe you could
help me out you're flirting in my door
everyone stand down stand down
i wouldn't take such extreme measures if
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team it's okay i'm not
okay each member has chosen for his or
her own completely unique set of
abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late i had to go
number two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate
i'm gonna go with afghan hound oh my god
is it a werewolf
yo they saw me next to a widow yo let me
out yeah he's not a werewolf okay he's a
weasel
he's harmless i mean he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but
you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known
only as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the calm